foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five but
before you dial the number you need to
know that this show today is dedicated
to generosity
so we're going to take calls from folks
today that have a giving story
a generosity story they were on the
receiving end or the giving end of
generosity because it is the season tis
the season
this is uh well Christmas reminds us how
important generosity is and uh it is
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality and my
daughter is my co-host today as we take
your calls about giving it's our annual
generosity show our annual giving show
so we want to hear from you if you've
got a great giving story you can jump in
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five Merry Christmas
to you triple eight eight two five five
two two five Kim is going to start off
this hour in Kenton Ohio hi Kim tell us
your giving story Merry Christmas
um hello Dave hello Rachel um thank you
for having me on the show
um this is my giving story back in
February my husband died of
um covid and I took a portion of the
life insurance money and gave it towards
my church's
um
debt elimination wow
November 26th my sons were there and we
all they saw me write the check fill out
the envelope we laid hands and prayed
over the check and the boys put it in
the offering and my husband he was a
amazing Giver he gave to people all the
time he gave cars and trucks and vans
and cash to families in need he gave
wood and fuel oil to older people that
needed heat in the winter he just gave
it was his it was who he was
and um it was such a blessing to be his
wife it's such a blessing to give
in his honor and his legacy and our
church
um
there down to 270
000 left on their mortgage and 12 years
ago it was a 14 million dollar mortgage
so wow wow
that's so powerful
I'm so sorry for your loss
um thank you thank you that was the
motivator you know for this
um so I'm curious for you when you
received that life insurance obviously
his legacy was one of giving right the
way you just described to him is just
beautiful
um so what made you choose this specific
way to give
well
I felt that you know
every year he gave to the Legacy
offering and there's usually a project
that the church is doing
and this was his life insurance money
um
I wanted to give a tithe of it to the to
the Legacy offering so that he would
continue giving throughout all the years
as a legacy
um
I was going he wanted me to retire he
wrote these letters about me retiring
and he had me call Dave I actually wrote
a letter because I didn't think I could
get through the
um phone call but um Dave gave me a um
a coach a financial coach her name is
Lisa Lisa Barber and I worked with her
for the last 10 months and throughout
that process I came to I didn't want to
retire I want to continue to fulfill
God's will for my life which I'm a
teacher and I love teaching children how
to read I love being at the school I
feel like I'm here for such a time as
this so instead of taking
a portion of the re of the life
insurance and buying out so that I could
retire early
instead I decided to continue working
continuing following God's will for my
life and take God's will for his life
and pay you know give it to the legacy
of my husband for God's kingdom to grow
that's that's how I came Acro came about
that whole process at Lisa helped me
make these decisions that I did make
them myself you know wow
well at least as a precious lady you got
a hold of a good one there so that's
good stuff dad I love her yes yes I do
love her what an eventful thank you for
giving me that yeah what an eventful
year you've had uh unbelievable highs
unbelievable lows and uh it's very
poignant very beautiful great story and
how old are your sons
24 year old and a 23 year old okay
young men were able to sit there and see
their dads uh see their mom write this
check from their dad's life insurance
into this and and they get to have that
imprint on the rest of their life that
thumb print on the rest of their life
that was very well played
um thank God that I was able to do that
for for all you know for all to see that
yeah amen thank you for sharing Miss Kim
God bless you honey and a Merry
Christmas to you that's a great story a
horrible start uh to the story in a
beautiful end or a beautiful Next Step
whatever we want to call it I don't know
how to say how what you're saying that
but uh uh without saying something dumb
and awkward but yeah but uh uh it's
amazing that when people are in pain
uh that generosity is something that
automatically comes to mind yeah that's
what I was going to say is that there's
like a lot of these stories that we hear
and that we'll probably hear today right
that there's there's some level of
people's stories that that pain is
always a part of it right that that is
that is a part of life and I think that
that scale is different for everyone
depending on their specific story uh but
man the depths of that pain in her case
I'm like was the depths of her longing
in that selflessness right and I think
that that's a way to even combat and and
and I'm sure helped with the grief like
there's a level too of when you're
giving and serving it's you are putting
your eyes elsewhere and there's just
Beauty in that absolute Beauty
generosity is uh
considerably underrated as a healing
agent
it completely changes the chemistry of
your body it completely changes the set
of your emotions it completely changes
your spiritual walk it literally will
change the way you walk
when you become generous and the more
outrageously generous you become the
more free you are as a person you find
very few people who are depressed who
are outrageously generous
something to think about
because what happens is I mean chemicals
are released in your body that you get a
high from being generous I mean it's
it's unbelievable it is the most fun to
have with money there's so much to it
there's more so much more than the math
so much more than the individual person
that's helped on the other end of the
check
there's so so many layers to this
subject
this is the annual giving show on the
Ramsay show and we want to hear from you
Rachel Cruz is with me the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five call us with your giving story
or your receiving story we're
celebrating generosity
Merry Christmas
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today as we talk about giving
today this is our annual giving show
we're talking about generosity if you
have a story about generosity giving or
uh or or receiving that is inspiring and
will help everyone all of us expand our
our vision for generosity that's what
this is for the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Wayne is in Lincoln Nebraska hi Wayne
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks for having me sure
my uh
so after my first deployment I came came
home in 2009 and was out running around
eating all the food that I'd missed and
stopped at a burger joint there was a
homeless man
walking along the sidewalk so I just
offered to have lunch offered for him to
come have lunch with me and we ended up
talking for several hours but
he had gotten married in 1966 in 67 he
was sent over to Vietnam where he was
shot in the head and suffered some
severe brain damage he was unable to
take care of himself and true to their
vows his wife took care of him until the
day that she died and so for three years
he was completely homeless had no idea
what to do
um we had lunch
and I ended up working with some of my
unit leadership and some local veterans
organizations and this guy ended up
getting
a full VA disability and
now has a place to stay in a VA Veterans
Home in uh in that Dallas area wow
man you took it up you took it up and
ran with it way to go dude
but it doesn't take a a huge Act of
money to completely change somebody's
life and I think sometimes people get
overwhelmed with that thought yeah it
some it often takes more time than it
does money
in your case that's for sure
time and effort yeah
and a lot of caring yeah and that still
is a um an act of generosity in in a
maybe even in a greater way because so
many people don't have any time they
don't take any time they don't have any
margin in their lives to stop and
concentrate on someone else for a few
minutes they're so busy doing themselves
what's his name Wayne
Jared Jared okay so for you
as you know you you obviously have
completely changed the course of his
life which is just absolutely incredible
and like you said I love
that it's more on that time and effort
standpoint not just money right you you
walked with him to be able to do that so
you changed his life what ways has he
impacted you on you know even a
day-to-day basis how how has your life
been shifted because of him
prior to that event happening I'd kind
of grown up with this belief that
homeless people were you know lazy and
drug addicts that stereotype that's not
always true and after this I started
slowing down and really thinking Well
everybody's got a story everybody's
really got problems
and it's never what it looks like on the
surface
that's for sure
that's for sure everybody's got a story
wow powerful dude powerful well done sir
thank you for calling with your story
Merry Christmas to you Wayne hey
everyone that is calling in with their
uh giving story today and the phone
number here is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll receive the
live and give bundle the live and give
box it has in it a one-year membership
to Financial Peace University it has in
it a Total Money Makeover book it has in
it a baby steps millionaires book and
that is on sale for 99 which is about 50
60 bucks off of retail right now at
ramseysolutions.com but each of these
callers will be getting that uh live and
give box uh as they call in today and of
course
you know if you've got somebody that's
just getting started with the stuff you
hand them The Total Money Makeover book
maybe you're down the road a little ways
and you're ready to start really doing
your investing and you're going to read
the
baby steps millionaires book
um and maybe you've got someone that
needs to go through Financial Peace
University or maybe it's you
so there's three different things there
that apply to different situations
different places people are in their
money journey and so the live and give
box be sure to check that out and like I
say we're giving everybody the calls
into day one Mary is with us Mary's in
Atlanta Georgia hi Mary welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi hi Dave hi Rachel um
thank you all so much for having me on
the show to share um our story a small
gift but one that I hope has been having
a big positive impact on my niece and
nephew love it tell us about it
so just a little bit of brief background
during covid lockdowns my niece and
nephew really started to struggle they
were both in middle school at the time
their social life evaporated their
mental health plummeted and they
unfortunately started failing classes in
virtual school so at the time my husband
and I had just had our first baby I was
actually laid off in 2020 at seven
months pregnant so we were living off of
just his income and our budget was
pretty tight but we decided initially
just to host each kid for a special
weekend once a month to get them out of
the house they can do very fun cheap
things in our neighborhood and generally
just love on them my assistant sisters
excuse me my husband's sister actually
joined us in this and so it became this
really fun family affair later the three
of us decided to offer a grade Bounty it
was pretty generous 20 bucks for each a
10 bucks for each B and I am
unbelievably happy to say that my niece
has made a healthy return on the time
she's invested in studying for about two
years now she just started high school
this fall and earned a 4.0 her first
semester we're really really proud of
her
so this is especially important because
her parents do not have any money to pay
for her college but the state of Georgia
will cover all of her tuition through
the Hope Scholarship if she has at least
a 3.0 GPA at the end of high school so
we've talked
us about student loan and how she could
avoid them and she is really eager to
keep those out of her
encouraging her to do that
my nephew's also gotten himself a
part-time job and his grades started to
improve too so I did want to just say
thank you to y'all for the teaching and
encouragement that you offer around
Financial generosity because I struggle
with the scarcity mindset sometimes so
it's hard to do for me on occasion but I
really like the idea of living with an
open hand and just practicing generosity
like a muscle until you're good at it
amen well done good job Mary that's fun
hey be sure to walk those kids uh The
Borrowed future documentaries free to
watch on YouTube now
I know we usually watch a movie when
they come over for weekends and I keep
telling my husband let's watch Barbara's
future there's fun stuff on Disney plus
and that'll seal in the uh no uh no debt
to college idea if you watch that you
see how horrible the whole student loan
system is yeah that'll seal that in for
sure hey uh let me ask you something you
said scarcity mindset and you're
practicing a new muscle
um
what does it do to the scarcity mindset
my theory is is that it moves you from
scarcity towards abundance the more
you're generous or maybe it's the other
way around maybe you're after you move
more towards abundance you're willing to
be more generous I don't know which is
the cause which is the effect which the
chicken the egg what do you think Mary
I I really think it's about perspective
because you know I'm sitting in my
little house in Atlanta that my husband
and I own thinking oh we don't have
enough to give away but there are so
many people with less than that who
really don't have enough that they could
be generous and so it's more about
recognizing what's fear and what's fact
and then deciding like that you want to
share what you have with people that you
really love or just people in your
community and I mean once we started
doing it really has gotten so much
easier and so much more joyful to do I'm
I'm not gonna lie like the first few
times we did this we started like giving
money away I was like oh God how I want
to make the grocery budget this month
but really it's been absolutely fine you
hadn't missed a meal
no
well Mary what I love about your story
is I'm like you were so
um you took the needs very specifically
of what they needed in the time right so
like during the lockdown it's like they
just needed to get out of the house and
that's what you provided and then as
they were starting to not do great in
school then you're like okay well let's
plug in here so it's like whether it's
the time the money all of it but but
being so intentional Mary which you
really are in their lives to see what do
they need and what can you do to maybe
help fill that Gap and so that's I think
that's amazing so really really well
done yeah extremely well done Mary Merry
Christmas to you excellent excellent job
it is uh you know that that kind of
intentionality comes from Real Love
and that that's tied into real
generosity this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Merry Christmas America Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
bestselling author my daughter is my
co-host today this is our annual giving
show where we celebrate generosity where
you have been able to do something for
someone or for something and you want to
celebrate that generosity or maybe
you're celebrating someone did something
for you it's okay either way we all love
these stories generous people make us
smile generous people make our eyes leak
we love generous people and all of us do
all humans do I mean you got to be a
real weirdo to hate somebody that's
generous so that's what we're
celebrating this hour and this day on
our annual giving show the phone number
here is triple eight eight two five five
two two five and part of this giving
show tradition is we always bring in one
of our our some of our 1100 members of
Ramsey Solutions our team members and
Jess is on the stage Jessica's with us
and uh got a great giving story hey Jess
how are you doing how are y'all doing
great great merry Christmas Merry
Christmas well tell everybody about your
story it's fabulous yes so you talk
about people giving to you and you being
able to give to other people this story
is a little bit of both so about four
and a half of actually five and a half
years now years ago now we actually met
the sweetest most adorable little baby
girl
and she was a family member to some of
uh our church church members there and
she couldn't be with her family and so
she needed a home she needed a parents
and I'm not a super cautious person but
my husband is ultra cautious and
normally he has to think through things
especially something very serious it's
usually weeks sometimes months yeah it's
just like serious parenting is pretty
serious way up there on the serious
scale yeah yes so but we just kind of
made eye contact at church as as the
request was being given to find a home
for this little girl and she's just
adorable and so we kind of make eye
contact and didn't even have to talk
about it we came together after that and
said are you in like yep I'm I'm in are
you in my husband said yeah I'm in and
so we at that that's a long conversation
very you know 30 seconds long maybe cops
and so after that we decided to get
custody of our Gabby girl
and it was about a four and a half year
long process to actually solidify the
adoption
and so a long process I learned a lot of
things about the legal system some
things I didn't really care to know
about but I feel like I'm kind of a
lawyer at this point after all of that
yeah I don't know um and so the legal
system is enough to uh well we'll just
move on yeah yeah yeah and so but one of
the interesting things through that is
when we met Gabby we actually were still
in debt and we were working our way out
of that and one of the opportunities
with that was not only getting out of
debt but finances was one of my biggest
concerns going through this adoption I
was thinking we got to get out of debt
so that we can adopt this child well
finances was the least of my concerns
God provided people were generous to us
we had the funds to pay for it the
emotional side was the hard part and one
of the stories with that was we were
actually we didn't have we had custody
of Gabby what we hadn't adopted her yet
at her one-year birthday party at our
house we had actually had all of our
friends all of our family at our house
just hanging out and we had some medical
debt that was standing out there from my
husband had a medical emergency and so
we're working through that we were going
to get that paid off but we have been
served we've been served to collections
and so we had hear this knock on the
door during this birthday party and all
our friends and family are there and I'm
thinking oh is somebody late you know
are they arriving late so they knocked
on the door and then my husband gets to
the door and he says there's a police
officer out here and I was like why in
the world would there be a police
officer and he was trying to be kind to
us but I was like what in the world's
going on and he said you you've been
served your your debt's going to
collections and my pride just dropped I
was like what in the world we're fine
we're okay but that's the moment where I
was like I've got to get out of debt and
I've got to give this child a home and
so we were able to do both and not only
were we able to be generous to her she's
been so generous to us oh she changed
everybody she's amazing she's an amazing
kid now she's she's a great kid so very
cool so she's been with you how long now
um she just turned to six this past
weekend and she's been with us since she
was almost a year old yeah all right
yeah a long time that year oh yes okay
so there's been a lot of you know a lot
of people that listen have adopted
Foster they're kind of in that in that
space as well with that parental role so
so talk to the parents out there that
maybe have adopted or are fostering and
you guys have walked through this over
years so what encouragements do you have
for those parents because I know that
there's really hard days yes uh through
it all like you were talking about even
just the emotional side but man how that
giving and consistency yes and opening
your home in your heart I'm like oh like
yeah that that just that encouragement
to parents that may feel discouraged
this holiday season absolutely yes hold
your kids close that quality time it can
still be yours even if you don't have
the title and we were parents before we
even had the title if we left it up to
the government we may never be parents
so that's one of the things that we're
like you know what we're going to be
parents of this this child and I would
encourage all the potential parents out
there love those kids hug those kids
give those kids everything that you can
because they don't know they're going to
be grateful for whatever you can give
them and they're going to give back to
you tenfold yeah
just you've been with us how long almost
10 years I thought so and tell everybody
what you do I'm a senior customer
success agent on Ramsey trusted all
right there it is senior customer that's
how that works hey I claim that too
absolutely absolutely you do a great job
and we're honored to have you as part of
this family and uh honored to honor Miss
Gabby and your whole family is cat are
you bringing her over for the camera
good good yeah absolutely yeah she's
coming up here we go there's Miss Gabby
all right that way everybody can meet
her on YouTube very cool good stuff hey
Jessica thank you very much very well
done proud of you thank you Merry
Christmas miss Gabby
thank you all right
very good stuff oh the adoption and the
Foster system is a
uh there's such a need and but it's
never an easy process it's always it's
always difficult yeah I mean I mean
that's
it's about widows and orphans and you're
just like oh like as of as a mom with
three little ones like anytime there's
stories like that like would just just
talk through or you you know we have
families and we know that that Foster
and you just hear that's I mean there's
a level like the ultimate selflessness I
mean you are giving your life away for a
child that didn't choose that story you
know it made me cry
um I don't know so I think it's just
it's just beautiful so I just commend
her and her husband so much because it's
hard being a parent's hard let alone you
know having that other dynamic in there
but then the Redemption and the beauty
of you know these kids and just even
with Gabby I'm like you know how her
story is completely different because
someone chose to do something and a
really radical a radical way yeah very
cool
neat people neat people that's what this
is about open phones if you want to talk
giving this is your day it is our annual
giving show the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Rachel you and I first wrote about
this a long long time ago in your first
number one bestseller smart money smart
kids and you've talked about it even
more since then the idea that
contentment
generosity and
um gratitude are all intertwined and
they're all choices and they all end up
affecting your your wealth building they
all end up affecting your money yeah I
mean I think it's
people sometimes are like you know it
makes no sense when you guys encourage
us to be giving even while we're getting
out of debt or while we're saving up for
the emergency fund like as we're going
through our process to get a solid
Financial Foundation under us you're
wanting us to like let money not go
towards the debt and get it paid off
faster but to actually give and you know
so like we'll hear those conversations
sometimes or Those Questions by people
with people and and the answer always is
yes because What Not only would it what
it changes in you but creating that
habit of generosity and and the change
of your heart of what ends up happening
and and suddenly you know when you're
generous gratitude flows through when
you're generous you realize gosh all the
stuff I thought I needed I
I really don't I don't I don't need to
be fulfilled by that you know there's a
joy out of living without open hands
that really does bring a level of
contentment that I think in turn allows
you to get out of debt even faster and
say even more that's the weirdest thing
and it's a beautiful formula that I kind
of feel like we've cracked in a great
way so it's wonderful the Triad of
generosity contentment and
generosity contentment and gratitude the
Triad yeah and all of these are things
you can just choose to practice and they
uh they build on each other and they
take you where you want to go with this
money stuff this is the annual giving
hour our giving show here on the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five this is your last day
to enter the Ramsey Christmas Cash
giveaway the giveaway ends tonight at 11
59 PM Central Time
so if you haven't yet go to
ramseysolutions.com giveaway
you know for your chance to win the five
thousand dollar grand prize of course no
purchase necessary
and of course you have to be 18 or older
to win that's ramseysolutions.com
giveaway don't forget that our 10 sale
is still going on and you can get our
number one best-selling books like all
of Rachel's number one best-selling
books there's three of them and a couple
of mine The Total Money Makeover number
one ten dollars baby steps millionaire
is my latest number one ten dollars and
speaking of Total Money Makeover when
you get the book we often tell people to
flip through and read the stories first
because that's where the hope is it's in
the stories of people who got free from
debt change their family tree because
they finally dealt with the person in
the mirror these stories are powerful
this stuff works be weird head on over
to ramseysolutions.com and check the ten
dollar sale out this is our annual
giving show and we're talking to you
about your giving story or your
receiving story that is inspiring open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Leslie is in Fort
Worth Texas hi Leslie Merry Christmas
hey Dave Merry Christmas and thank you
so much for letting me talk to you today
about my story well tell us we'd love to
hear it
about seven years ago my son Jackson was
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma he was
eight years old at the time and we were
very blessed he went through treatment
pretty quickly and was pronounced good
to go after about nine months well at
the end of his journey through that the
hospital referred us to an organization
called a wish with wings and they're a
wish granting organization here in Texas
and any kid who goes through a situation
like Jackson where they face a
life-threatening condition can be
granted a wish and they granted his wish
and he got to meet Dude Perfect and we
got to go to Disney but that wasn't the
most important part like like you are
Dave they are dealers in Hope and they
gave our family hope they were just such
a sweet organization full of loving
people and when you've got a kid with
cancer even family members and Friends
don't always know how to help you and
how to be there for you and this
organization of people did and we fell
in love with them so about a year after
Jackson finished chemotherapy he wanted
to do something special so Jackson and I
did a 200 mile hike and raised twenty
five thousand dollars from family and
friends who pledged to wish with wings
for him doing this hike how old was he
then he was nine years old oh my God you
did a 200 mile hike one year after chemo
with a nine-year-old and he did it in 14
days
tough tough little man well now he's a
tough bigger man but still nothing to
stop this guy wow yeah yeah and uh so
but still our family wanted to do more
uh because we just love these people and
we started volunteering and when they
had events we would go volunteer for
those events I launched a business not
long after that and the business has
started doing well so in the last few
years our family has been able to donate
65 000 to wish with wings and that's
enough to Grant eight which eight wishes
and then my wonderful children have
gotten their friends involved every time
my kid has a birthday party he's
collecting gifts for other kids who are
sick who have cancer every time their
school has some kind of fundraising
opportunity they plug this organization
because they care about them so you talk
a lot Dave about changing your family
tree and to me this changed our family
tree because someone gave us hope and
taught us that our number one goal
should be helping other people have hope
so we are just totally sold out on
helping this organization
else that is for kids with cancer yeah
what's the name of it one more time a
wish with wings a wish with wings very
cool yeah this whole situation was a
force multiplier
one plus one doesn't equal two in this
deal one plus one is equal ended up
equaling a hundred
well and you can take a bad situation
and you can let it gnaw at you or
pretend it didn't happen or you can
decide you're going to make it into
something better and while I'll never be
grateful that my kid went through cancer
I am so grateful that now we understand
what it's like to be the people who are
the recipient of bad situations that are
not they're doing and it's taught
everyone in our family including both
our kids compassion and love and we
really now in our family budget we put
giving as a top line item there are so
many things we just don't need and we
thought we did we would much rather give
back and I know that sounds so cheesy
and over the top but it's true because
when we see these other families they
don't have it easy like we did
well yeah and when you face something
Leslie like that like when your child is
sick
and
you know and I'm sure you got the the
fear of what you know the ultimate fear
of what what if we what if we lose him I
mean all I'm sure you go through all
those emotions I can't even imagine
um and I think too it's that perspective
that when you realize wow he came out of
this and like it's life is so short and
you know all the stuff that we think is
going to make us happy in this life that
we go out and try to purchase and
experience all this stuff that we're
just like go go go go go in the
consumeristic aspect of our world that
we think is going to give us joy you
know you in turn are like you know you
realize oh my gosh no like it it truly
is this giving back out of this pain and
the story that you guys went through but
but it's this perspective that you have
that you're like okay it's you know we
could go buy a bunch of stuff with this
money or we can give it
and in your life like you are you are
putting True Value
um on where value should be so Leslie
that's absolutely incredible well done
Leslie Merry Christmas to you what a
great giving story what a great giving
story yeah so it turns out pushing by
now by now by now filling your cart
is probably not what life's about yeah
who knew sorry Amazon but yeah there you
go hey a few weeks ago we told you our
studio sponsors here PODS moving and
storage we're going to be entering uh
the giving season they're going to join
us on this whole giving Crusade they're
holding a sweepstakes to give away a
free move or storage rental for one
Ramsey listener we're excited to share
the winner today it seemed fitting to do
here on the giving show because this was
up to a five thousand dollar value
that's generous PODS moving thank you
very cool stuff so congratulations to
Andrea K Andrea recently moved from
Apollo Beach Florida to just a little
ways up the road here in Hermitage
Tennessee she shared that she's ecstatic
to have her move paid for by pods and
hey who wouldn't be welcome to Tennessee
Andrea and uh the giveaway is over if
you're looking for a company that does
will that will work with you take care
of you cause you to have a great moving
experience well the PODS moving and
storage folks are the people and they're
the only ones that are Ramsay trusted in
the moving provider space you can check
them out at pods.com Ramsay we
appreciate their partnership here with
us their sponsorship of the show one of
the reasons you are able to get this
show all the ways you get this show is
our sponsors the advertisers the people
that are with us and the studio
sponsorship's a big deal so the PODS
moving and storage people are great
folks and we are kind of hard to work
with in terms of we don't endorse just
anybody we don't put Ramsay trusted on
just anybody just because they've got
the money
and we'd rather just sit here with a
studio then the PODS moving in storage
Studio but the pods people are great
folks I personally met with a lot of
their leadership team they do a great
job they give discounts to the military
those of you in the military you move
all the time and they give you great
discounts they're great American company
and um and Andrea k okay just got her
move paid for there you go that's pretty
cool very nice yeah moving can be
it can be pricey so when you just get it
paid for you're like yeah it's great it
can be really pushy if you go with one
of those companies that mistreats you
yeah it's uh they mistreat your stuff in
the process yes yeah pod's moving and
storage thanks guys it's a giving show
today here on the Ramsay show Rachel
Cruz is my co-host
you hang with us we'll be here
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the pots moving in storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where debt is dumb
Cassius king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
thank you for joining us America Rachel
Cruz Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author three times over and
my daughter is my co-host today as we
take your calls today we're talking
about giving this is our annual giving
show if you have a great giving story
some outrageous generosity that you
received or that you caused to happen
meaning you gave hey we want to hear
inspiring giving and generosity Stories
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Merry
Christmas America tis the season for
generosity
this is the place where we celebrate
that we teach you to live like no one
else so later you can live and
give like no one else generous people
make us smile generous people make our
eyes leak and that's what this show is
all about open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
starting off this hour with a giving
story Ben in Birmingham Merry Christmas
Ben Merry Christmas thank you for having
me on the show Absolutely so tell us
your giving story
so um this is actually kind of a
receiving story that my siblings got but
um so my parents and our family have
been missionaries for the past 20 years
my parents move overseas uh early 2000
but prior to that my dad while he was in
seminary was working at FedEx and they
met some friends who basically became
really close family friends and as my
dad was was working he kind of made his
way up in the ranks that this job where
he was working and when they decided to
go overseas this family friend basically
said that because you know my dad was
willing to give up his career and kind
of go overseas to serve that they were
going to basically purchase uh cars all
of their children whenever they came
back for college so there's five of us
five children wow so whenever we ended
up all coming back he essentially bought
a 15 to 20 000 car for each of us he
paid for the insurance for the first
year for that car he paid for basically
all the maintenance for the first year
on those cars so kind of over the course
of I would say probably 10 years as each
of our siblings came back he ended up
probably paying about a hundred thousand
dollars worth of you know money that he
put into buying cars for us to
essentially get established and have a
way to be you know transported while we
were back in the country and our parents
were still overseas so it's pretty
incredible gift on his part
um and a pretty awesome story that I've
actually never really gotten to tell a
lot of people so
very cool I love that
yeah I love the way the whole thing went
down it's a friendship and they just
admired your mom and dad and the you
know nothing you could listen if you
want to do something for someone and
blow their minds do something for their
kids
exactly I mean that touched your mom and
dad more than than if they'd gotten the
money directly or if he'd wrote them 100
000 check to underwrite their their
Ministry or their mission work uh it
wouldn't have meant near as much as what
he did yeah exactly and basically it
provided because they were still
overseas when we would come back for
college so essentially it provided us
transportation to get to our school uh
school during the semesters our summer
jobs during the summer to basically go
and see our our extended family in
different parts of the country because
without that I mean my parents
definitely couldn't have afforded to buy
cars for us whenever we needed to come
back to the States for school yeah
absolutely pretty tremendous tremendous
gift on his part for sure okay Ben this
might be a weird question in the middle
of your giving story but yeah once some
calls we've taken on the show some
people have a really hard time receiving
gifts so how did your parents what was
kind of their posture when this friend
came forward and said hey I wanna
I wanna give your kids cars when they
come home
um you know like were they was it a
hundred percent just they accepted it in
this humble Spirits or did they have any
level of like oh man we wish we couldn't
do it we can't do that for our kids and
that receiving you know because I want
to speak to that in a in a in
encouraging people to receive the gift
because sometimes sometimes I think
people struggle receiving as well
yeah I think it was honestly kind of
easy for them because I think that they
knew that that was something that they
weren't going to be able to provide for
us whenever we came back to the States
um so in a way it was kind of maybe a
relief for them and kind of a burden off
of their shoulders in terms of having to
provide for their kids and that in that
circumstance for sure so I think it was
honestly kind of kind of a relief yeah
no I love that that's that's what I pray
you know people's heart is but I think
sometimes people need to hear that to
say hey it's okay to receive and you can
do that like it doesn't speak to who you
are if you're the one given something so
um so I love that that's so great
very cool Ben thank you for sharing that
story man
absolutely appreciate it absolutely
Merry Christmas good stuff open phones
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five Patricia is in Connecticut
hi Patricia tell us your giving story
Merry Christmas by the way
you too
recipient of outrageous generosity that
I wanted to be able to share with you
guys and I haven't really told many
people this story
um because I felt like it wasn't my
story to tell since I was the recipient
but it's been two years and I think it's
time for everyone to know that the
business that I run was given to me
um in October of 2020. so I was given a
small business which is actually a
self-serve frozen yogurt shop
oh wow so how did that get about
um I got laid off from Corporate America
back in 2014
um and I decided I didn't want to go
back to that
so I picked up a part-time job at the
local froyo shop I'm right in town
um in
November of 2015.
um and then my husband and I actually
started the baby steps January of 2016.
and then we finished our baby steps we
paid off all our debt and then somewhere
along the line the the owners had asked
me because I was still working at the
frozen yogurt shop
um to purchase the store or they had
numerous stores so they you know had it
had been discussed
um but they also knew I didn't borrow
money so uh I would always tell them no
because I couldn't afford to own a
business of course
um and then covet of course came in
April 2020 we have to close the shop
down so I was actually unemployed um it
was self-served frozen yogurt so it just
wasn't sustainable
which was devastating
um but we actually did reopen in July of
2020.
um so my bosses decided to reopen and
that's what we did
um and then a month later they one of
the bosses pulled me aside into the into
the back kitchen which is never a good
sign right I was nervous
um and uh he had asked me if I wanted
the store if I wanted to you know take
the store be the store owner and I said
I don't really know what you mean what
does that mean and he said we're going
to give you the store but you're gonna
get this store with equipment that is 11
years old they have been in business for
11 years yeah I'll tell you what I want
to hear the rest of this and I'm up on
Commercial because I don't want to run
this into the ground it's too good hang
with us through the commercial Patricia
we'll hear the rest of the story here on
the annual giving show on the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
Christians helping other Christians by
sharing each other's medical bills the
medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs we
like that it's a non-profit Ministry and
that we were being better stewards of
our money all while helping other
families
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget that's
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is our annual giving
show here on the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls with giving stories
receiving stories this is all about
generosity live like no one else and
later you can live and give like no one
else we were in the middle of Patricia's
story in Connecticut she's left
Corporate America went to work for a
frozen yogurt shop and they offered to
sell it to her a couple of times and
then during covet after going back to
work the owner walks in one day and says
they are offering to give it to her now
let's pick that story up there Patricia
thank you
thank you yeah that's pretty much how it
went
um so like I said they offered to give
me the store
um and the store had been in business
for about 11 years already so of course
the equipment you know the machines all
that stuff was 11 years old
um so that happened in about August and
sure enough October 14th of 2020 we
closed on the business
um I started you know an LLC I opened
new bank accounts
um and I did all that and we actually
closed and here I am two you know two
and a half years later as a small
business owner in a very small town
um but enjoying every second of it so
wow what do you what prompted them to do
that
uh I like I said they had offered a few
times I think you know when when
customers would come in I was always
there so so customers would say oh is
this your store and I would say no no no
but they would always say well you treat
it like your store because I had so much
passion for what I was doing and it
sounds silly people think it's silly but
you know at my interview with with the
store owners at when I started I had
told you know I had told them I treat
every job like it's a career
um so I'm going to have a lot of passion
I love being around people of course
there's you know our clientele is
generally kids uh so I think that after
covid there was a lot of restrictions
um and they actually own a hardware
store in the same Plaza uh so they were
really you know we all know everyone was
stuck home during covid so they were
just slammed over there I mean they were
every day all day everybody was home at
the hardware store so I think it was
just time to to figure something out to
Let It Go ah okay all right but through
your diligence of being so excellent you
know at your job
you're the person that shined through to
yeah to receive that which is which is
amazing
it really is and it's been amazing and
it's more than just a small business
year you know it's definitely a family
business I'm actually looking inside the
store right now my husband's covering
for me while I'm on the phone with you
guys my mom does all our shopping at
Costco every day so you know my retired
mom guessed it with a Costco every day
it's basically a joy for her and uh my
son does all the heavy lifting when
orders come in or take some garbage out
at night you know I have a bunch of
great employees also but um it's the
customers that really make it just
really worthwhile it's it's definitely
what I feel I was called to do oh I
think you were yeah you're the backbone
of America small business people like
you that's what makes this entire Place
run it is not large corporate Goobs and
it's not the government it's people like
you that cause make this country great
the free enterprise system causes people
like you to shine and people like the
former owners that were generous to you
to shine yeah absolutely that's
incredible just hand it over a business
yeah pretty cool that's awesome very
very very cool stuff hi Patricia thank
you for sharing that Merry Christmas to
you we appreciate you hanging out with
us today this is our annual giving show
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself
whyblinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code Ramsay to
get the best deal so today's question
comes from Jim in Florida I'm struggling
in giving recently because I have plans
that I need to accomplish buy a house
and get my small business off the
grounds I am a generous person but I
feel like I'm being cheap when it comes
to giving or when my wife gets to get
something for her friends or sister I
don't feel good while deep inside I know
that I am
I'm kind of confused if I'm changing to
a jerk and a selfish person but honestly
I'm doing it for my family so I need
some help
Jim
you know I mean I think that there's a
reality that when you have
your bases covered in your home and with
your family and the needs are provided
for it allows that generosity to flow
even greater uh with with maybe not as
much stress but this doesn't sound like
it's a I need to take care of my family
first I mean yes you want to be able to
buy a house for sure get my small
business off the ground you know but
this I would say to those gym that that
giving it doesn't have to be extravagant
and so starting to give a little until
you can give a lot right like if there
are things in your life that you're
wanting to do we all have that but that
doesn't mean you can't do both is what I
would say yeah
it sounds like
um
that the uh what's bothering you more
than the actual giving
um to the sister or to the friends or
whatever by your wife is that it feels
like that's blocking these other goals
and it's not that's the reality so the
way you can overcome that is just budget
for it
just say we're going to put a line item
in the budget you and your wife that
agree we agree on our entire budget but
we're going to agree on this is the
amount that that your wife has for
friends and sister
and uh don't go over that and then you
can use the rest of the budget
and see that you are able to accomplish
your goals of doing stuff in the
business or saving up for a home or
whatever you'll see that it you know if
you budget 100 bucks or something it's
not going to keep you from doing those
other things but this idea that it's not
got any limits on it
and um you're not in agreement when
she's doing these things that's where
the rub is
so if you were in agreement and it had a
reasonable limit and you were in
agreement on the limit on the amount
that that you know your wife has for
these two activities sister and friends
or whatever you want to call it uh then
you'd be okay with it uh but it's just
the ambivalence of it that is uh that's
probably throwing you because you're
you're obviously a person who who plans
but this is not something it doesn't
make you a bad person to say I'm going
to accomplish some goals
that's that's not a bad person now what
we do teach and have taught from the
very beginning around Ramsey and I think
it's good to get into this a little bit
is you want a baseline of giving that is
your normal rhythm
in your life
uh every month
and then you have when you are are
prospering and you've got extra money
above that normal budgeted giving that's
just flying around and you have a choice
between buying you know another thingy
and doing some generosity then you can
change and and do some generosity with
that Surplus money that extra money
that's from prospering but when you're
first starting out uh we teach people to
limit their giving to their Baseline
normal giving now for those of us that
are uh Christians Evangelical Christians
we teach and believe within our faith to
give a tithe a tenth of our income to
your local church that's your Baseline
that's your normal rhythm of giving you
don't stop doing that
and uh above the tithe is called
offerings and all throughout scripture
offerings come from Surplus from
prospering and so they would come after
you're out of debt
after you've taken care of your own
household
and and so this idea that you're
supposed to give away the rent money
uh and your your kids are become
homeless because you were generous
that's absurd
and it's not scriptural for those of you
that are Christians by the way take care
of your own household first or you're
worse than unbeliever
that's scriptural and that's not lacking
in generosity it doesn't make you a bad
person quite the opposite it makes you a
good person yeah absolutely so we start
with taking care of our house then we
can expand and say we're going to take
care of people outside of our house and
then we can expand and say we're going
to change our family tree and then we
can expand and say let's change our
whole community
but that's that all comes from the
Surplus above the normal rhythm of
giving and I think you need to put a
rhythm of giving Jim in your budget for
your wife to have some freedom without
being worried about you being upset
about it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
this is our annual giving show the show
where we talk about the power of
generosity if you've got a great story
that's inspiring on where you've given
or received we would love to hear it and
you can call us at triple eight eight
two five five two two five speaking of
giving uh this Show's free for you on
podcast on YouTube it's free for you on
680 radio stations all across America
tens of millions of you join us every
week thank you we appreciate that we are
grateful for you uh but it's time for
you to give back
you need to go and uh leave a rating a
five-star rating at uh wherever you
listen and don't leave a one star
they're not valuable at all that's why
they call them one star put a five star
on there thank you we appreciate that
and you need to subscribe it helps other
people be notified by all the algorithms
and uh oh the various things that the
wonderful people on the internet do to
allow you to know that these things
exist it's caused by you subscribing so
subscribe leave a uh a rating and share
the show tell people where you listen to
it on talk radio send a link to your
podcast off of Spotify or apple or
wherever it is or YouTube say Hey you
ought to check these guys out the
information is real and it's not you
know we're not on here whining and
crying and angry every day we're here
helping people and so it's kind of an
unusual show in that regard you ought to
spread the spread the word we had to get
more of this kind of thing out there in
this world today so open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five all of our callers today will be
getting the live and give box which has
in it The Total Money Makeover book the
uh baby steps millionaires book and a
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University this allows you to break this
up and and give it away or book A book A
book a class however you want to do it
or use the whole thing yourself the live
and give Box by the way if you want to
buy it it's only 99 bucks at Ramsey
Solutions and that's about 50 60 bucks
under what all of those items retail for
so it's a good deal
the live and give box one of our
traditions on the giving show that we do
is we bring on a few of our Ramsay team
members a few of the 1100 folks in this
building who all practice generosity at
different levels and have great stories
but uh no question about it Nathan is
with us and Nathan's got a great
generosity story hey Nathan how are you
good Dave how are you doing good Merry
Christmas same to you Merry Christmas a
little nerve-wracking putting on that
microphone isn't it in just a little bit
you're doing good you're gonna make it
so tell us your story man so so my my
mentor is a guy by the name of Stan
freeze super nice guy I worked with him
for uh 10 years and and
and he it's like over the years he's
just been so uh generous with me but
there there was one instance that it
that it completely floored me so
about uh 10 years ago
I was
I was working for him and I was actually
uh dating
um
um
she is actually now my wife uh Lauren
over here and and she and and so I
wanted to propose to her and I was just
just casually
uh talking to uh Stan about it one day
saying because you know because back
then this was actually before Dave and
so I was very stupid with money so I
didn't have the money to buy a ring for
for uh Lauren and so I so I was just
kind of kind of venting to him about it
one day didn't really think anything of
it and then
probably about two three days later he
actually drags me to one of the
conference rooms he says come here come
here come here so so
so we we
go to one of the conference rooms and he
gives me a box and he says here you go I
said okay so I open it up and it's a
really nice
ring and he just tells me you marry that
girl right now oh my God whoa
just like that yep yep so he gave he
gave you the engagement ring yes he did
wow that's cool yeah he was um
um because I was just flirting I said
Stan did you buy this and he said oh no
no no I I
um
I upgraded my my uh wife's ring so you
can have that one and I'm like oh my
gosh oh
oh my goodness wow that's very cool yeah
so how tempted have you been to do
something like that for somebody now
that you're out of debt and doing well
oh we're we just we just try to find
just seem like every opportunity my
life's very good with a discernment and
and so like when when she tells me we
need to
do you know to give somebody money or to
to you know to help them out help them
move I always listen to her and say okay
you you know what you're doing smart man
I was about the same thing I was like
smart man
oh that's amazing okay that's what I
love about this show though is I'm like
all the different ways that people step
into people's lives right and intersect
them in their stories where they're at
and be able to to help right and even
something like a proposal to be able to
say hey go marry that girl yeah here's
the ring and all that so stand stand
well done is it still the ring you have
your wife sitting over here yes yeah
yeah that's amazing absolutely amazing
there it is right there I like it so
great all right Nathan how long you been
with Ramsay since uh January all right
and tell everybody what you do here I am
a a
I'm a
a senior writer with the uh content team
absolutely very cool well thank you
brother for sharing that you did a great
job and that's a wonderful giving story
a wonderful Journey yes thank you Merry
Christmas y'all very good stuff fun fun
fun that's about as good as it gets I
love it hey open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Teresa wrote in uh from the baby steps
community on Facebook group if you
didn't know there's an official baby
steps Community with uh I think it's
over a million people in it now on
Facebook uh that's the official baby
steps Ramsey Community I don't know it's
called something like that today a
family member reached out asking for
help they're truly struggling receiving
food stamps but we're desperate for
items you cannot buy with food stamps in
less than an hour I was able to go
through my stockpile and fill a giant
Ikea bag with every possible item they
may need I'm gifting them toilet paper
cleaning supplies toothpaste deodorant
napkins
air freshener laundry soap dryer sheets
tissue trash bags and about a dozen
other household necessities on my way
over I'll be picking up dog food a gas
gift card and some gifts they can give
each other for Christmas I'm so thankful
for being debt free and that a bunch of
recent overtime is allowing me to help
them without it impacting my budget at
all I'm finally in the season of giving
and I couldn't be more thankful for that
oh I love that isn't that great and even
just that a little bit of that
convenience we're like all right I'm
gonna just go through my pantry and see
what I have here and be able to fill up
yeah
fill up a bag and be able to give it
away well and you can double up I mean
you know a lot of people
that you know they do the Costco thing
and they buy like six jars of peanut
butter and so they've got plenty you
know so you're not gonna go without
that's right that's right it works out
you know it's it's uh but just to be
able to do that spur of the moment and
catch somebody
Katie says for so many years I hated
December my husband's son and sister's
birthday plus Christmas I could never do
what I wanted this year I'm taking five
of us to Florida to my parents for
Christmas doing house projects for them
while there everyone can have what they
need and some of what they want for
Christmas birthday is plenty for giving
but the hardest part is keeping the list
straight check the bank a few minutes
ago because it felt too spendy and I had
only spent five percent of what was
allotted that's weird but good weird
keep going it gets fun yeah there you go
well you know what it takes the stress
off the holidays
um
one of the biggest elements of stress is
the financial threat of a hangover a
financial hangover that lasts till May
and when you've got your money in the
name of generosity right yeah all in the
name of generosity I hated December she
says yeah I get it I completely get that
this is the annual giving show here on
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well it's our annual giving show and all
day we've gotten to hear some incredible
stories of outrageous generosity this
stuff that gets us fired up it never
gets old guys if you've learned anything
from the stories we're hearing today I
hope you've learned that giving is the
most fun you can have with money
and you'll never have more fun than
helping someone else change their life
and one way you can do that is the live
and give box everyone today has been
getting the live and give box that calls
in with a giving story this is the Box
we gave everyone and today we're
offering it I thought it was 99 this is
even more
79.99 that's 20 off a normal that's like
half price for these items it's an
entire year of Financial Peace
University a copy of The Total Money
Makeover and a copy of baby steps
millionaires if there's someone in your
life who needs this and there is then
you give it to them you're going to show
them hope you're going to show them
Freedom they might be the ones calling
in on the next giving show because you
changed their life so get the live and
give box at ramsaysolutions.com super
sale on this thing
79.99 today you'll get it in time for
Christmas if you call it call in the day
or email her to click on the website
today and get it nobody call anymore and
again that's ramsesolutions.com
box you know we used to have people call
customer care and order stuff I bet
there's still a few that do there
probably is but but majority go on the
internet yes I mean it's just kind of a
foreign
like there's two of them I know it feels
like there's a lot I don't know there's
a lot of them all right Andrea is with
us in San Diego Andrea happy Christmas
to you Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas Dave and Rachel thanks
for having me on the show Absolutely
tell us your giving story please
I have a receiving generosity story my
husband and I got married
last year November in 2021 and we went
through Financial Peace University
together and we're on baby steps 3B and
he is active duty military and is
deployed this year so last month on our
one-year wedding anniversary since he's
gone I invited one of my best
girlfriends to go out to dinner with me
I said come to dinner with me this is
you know my treat let's just have a good
meal and good conversation you know get
whatever you want don't read the menu
from right to left and so we went out to
dinner
um at a really nice restaurant the the
type of restaurant where the manager is
you know roaming around talking to
people making sure everything's
satisfactory so the manager comes over
to our table and he asks you know if
we're visiting from out of town because
it was a pretty touristy area and we
said no we live here and so he said oh
you know what's what's the occasion then
and I said well it's my wedding
anniversary but I'm just here with my
friend because my husband is away for
work and he had a pretty good guess he
said oh is your husband in the military
and I said yeah he's a big military
Community here and he said oh you know
I'm sorry that you guys are apart but
you know hopefully we can make your meal
enjoyable and he asked me what what your
wedding anniversary it was and I just
you know held up one finger and his jaw
dropped and he said oh my gosh you know
I'm sorry and he said you know which
dessert on the menu were you girls
eyeing you know and so we looked at one
and picked one I can't even remember
what it is now and so of course they
they bring out that dessert which was
really nice and my friend and I are
finishing our meal and a waiter came
over
the server from the next section over it
wasn't our server and he comes up and
Taps me on the shoulder and he said that
the couple sitting in the next section
over the table behind us over her heard
me telling the manager that my husband
was deployed and it was my first wedding
anniversary and they had paid for our
entire meal I love it
as they should have well played that's
amazing yeah I thought you're gonna say
it was the manager that just like you
know picked it up and just said we got
it but it was another customer there
yeah that did that oh that's amazing
yeah we I kind of thought when the
manager was asking like oh which dessert
did you like you know I I thought that
maybe they were gonna comp the dessert
right right my friend and I were just so
shocked and luckily the couple was still
there they were like finishing up and so
I was able to turn around and I just
said thank you so much for you know your
generosity and they they said no thank
you thank your husband for his service
and
um yeah we I didn't really get to talk
with them much but I asked you know if
they were visiting or local and they
said that they were visiting on vacation
and they're flying home the next day and
and that was it and yeah just like the
spontaneity and like the impact like I
feel like that is just has such a bigger
impact on me than it did them and it's
like that makes my first anniversary
like so memorable absolutely how long
you been married now
uh well last month was our one year
anniversary
just happened wow okay
I love that and I love the picking up
the bill at restaurants Dave you're
really good at that like if you see
someone you know but I think because
I've been the recipient of that not to
that extent
um Andrea like yeah you're one year
anniversary with your husband deployed I
mean like that's just like over the top
but anytime someone does anything you
think oh my gosh like it is it's so
shocking to be on the receiving end and
especially with you in all those
circumstances like that feel that's just
I mean that like literally makes you
smile for weeks and weeks just thinking
about that yeah
very cool absolutely very cool hey and
do tell your husband we we appreciate
him too we love you guys we appreciate
what you do for America and um all the
men and women like him and like you and
the sacrifice that you do for him
um being uh at work in quotes and if
it's out of San Diego then that could
mean a whole lot of things yep that's
right so um yeah wow thank you thank you
very very much
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five I had the honor
of doing some things with SEAL Teams and
um of course they're based out of San
Diego and uh when they're at work uh
that means they're downrange uh it's
it's yeah that's when it's getting real
so somebody
is uh some bad guy somewhere is in
trouble that's what that means so uh
it's pretty serious and these men and
women they they are uh their level of uh
sacrifice their level of honor their
level of training is otherworldly it is
it's pretty amazing so anytime you've
got the opportunity to bless someone in
uniform uh please do it uh I don't care
if it's a police uniform a firefighter's
uniform or a set of Scrubs sitting there
or certainly a military uniform you just
reach over and do that every single time
and um you know I watched a guy the
other day somebody beat me to it I was
in a nice restaurant and this guy walked
in with a uh a Vietnam Veteran's hat on
the ball cap just a ball cap and
um he was uh elderly I mean this guy was
he was uh had I had served early in
Vietnam probably
um and uh but I mean it wasn't 30
seconds before people started lining up
to buy that tables from you know I mean
it didn't take but a second because you
could just look at that guy and go
that's a guy that needs to be honored
yeah you know absolutely pretty cool
stuff and there's something that happens
Rachel you're like right when somebody
buys your dinner like that regardless of
whether you're in a position of Honor
like that or not
um you're just maybe a position of need
uh whatever it is but there's something
about food
and that that transaction that makes the
receiving person feel very special yes
at absolutely
I hate
I hate story because it's nothing
compared to the all we just had but when
we we had been married about three
months and moved to Nashville I guess
it's been about four months and we were
starting off our jobs once and I mean in
our early 20s just doing it we had our
budget and we couldn't really go out to
eat like you know we were in the
Franklin area
um living in outside of Nashville and we
we kind of were like okay we can go out
to dinner like twice a week because kind
of like our Rhythm and so we went out on
a big date night to to Puckett's
downtown Franklin yeah uh one night
and some friends that we knew family
friends they were a little bit older uh
than us and again we had just been
married about four four or five months
and I remember we got Waters because we
didn't want to pay for a drink like I
mean we were like in that that season of
life and they paid for our meal and I
felt like I won the lottery I was like
it's not coming out of our budget like
oh my God yeah there's just it takes you
off guard yep there's something there's
something makes you feel special I know
it's a pretty cool but you do that great
you always are paying for people's meals
a restaurant and I just love that I I
think it's just a it's a beautiful it's
a beautiful thing fun stuff right it's
our annual giving show here on the
Ramsey show man I love generous people
they make us smile
they make our eyes leak this is the
Ramsay show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where debt is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people
build wealth do work that they actually
love and create real amazing
relationships
this day's shows are dedicated to giving
to generosity it's our annual giving
show in honor of Christmas time Merry
Christmas America
hey we're glad you're with us Rachel
Cruz Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
and we're taking uh your calls all about
giving we want to hear your stories that
are inspiring about giving and about
receiving generosity is the best thing
you can do with money it's the most fun
you'll ever have with money and we teach
you around here that you will sacrifice
to win you will live like no one else
so that later you can live and give
like no one else
so check it out we want to hear your
story open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five J in a
Washington DC is with us Merry Christmas
Jay how are you
hey Merry Christmas Dave and Rachel it's
real pleasure to talk with both of you
you too tell us your giving story
yes sir so I'd briefly like to share
today my family's progression of her
generosity over the past couple
Christmases and what we have planned
this year but first my why so my three
siblings and I were raised by a single
mother who's a real hero to all of us
all four of us are successful adults and
so ever real hard for helping single
moms however I can
over the years of course we were helped
by family and friends and strangers uh
in many ways and so I feel compelled to
do the same
in 2020 my wife's in my first Christmas
after completing baby step three we were
finally in a position that we could
expand our generosity to beyond our
church and we opted to find a deserving
stranger to help so I chose a diner type
restaurant a few days before Christmas
walked in and asked for the manager I
asked him if he had any single moms
working that day who could you use a
little hand up with a money gift for the
holiday now someone came to his mind
right away and he was able to help me
hand an envelope with a little over 200
to a grateful mom with two little ones
last year last year my family and I
became a little more strategic than that
I called a different restaurant about a
month before Christmas and asked for the
manager and if she had any single months
a good benefit from a monetary gift
there she immediately thought of one mom
who had recently successfully completed
rehab the manager and I skiing for a
weekend shift for when this particular
waitress was working and my wife and my
kids and I visited that restaurant for a
drink and a slice of pie in about
afternoon and we wanted to be anonymous
but evidently every employee in the
place knew besides the waitress that we
were about to give the gift they were
all smiling and watching us the whole
time and about 15 minutes in to our
visit we left the waitress 400 tip and
walked out
so this year Dave and Rachel I'm a
public school administrator and I get
daily reminders of how blessed my family
and I are through the course of serving
my school community and unfortunately
this year I learned recently the two
siblings who attend my school lost their
father to an accident and our school
team reached out to this newly widowed
mom to see how we could support and she
shared that among other things she was
struggling with finances and and because
her husband handled all the financial
matters I immediately thought that my
family and I could personally gift them
a subscription to Ramsay plus that she
would really benefit from the financial
coaching aspect of that so I called your
company and Rick one of your longtime
agents shout out to Rick answered I
explained the situation on behalf of the
company he generously gifted the year of
Ramsey plus to me to give to the Widow
I'm really grateful for your company for
stepping in to help and my of course my
family and I've been talking about how
we will outrageously give this year and
it will go to our Widow and our school
Community we have to help our single
moms especially those who are widowed
all these all these ladies are
superheroes absolutely yeah they are
they they do wear a cape every one of
them and uh most of them work multiple
jobs
just to get by and uh it's it's a very
real thing so you've touched a nerve you
really have that's fabulous
well done Jay thank you I love that Jay
thank you thank you so much for the
inspiration yeah and uh we we will
continue amen keep it up brother merry
Christmas too you're very cool very
amazing heart Jay you have you and your
sweet family and like that's
and I love the intentionality of calling
the restaurant talking to them right
like you kind of build it up and then
his kids Jay's kids you know going along
on that as well like there's there's
just life-changing things well if you if
you can more carefully identify the
target you're more likely to hit the
target yes random things you kind of get
sometimes when you're doing this kind of
weird generosity stuff you you get a
little nervous and you start kind of
thrashing around and get a little bit
random and sometimes you miss the target
yeah you know it's not your giving
doesn't do what is what you kind of
hoped it would do uh but in his case
he's being very selective and helping
someone go okay I love that that's a
that's a person uh that okay now I've
got that dialed in that's that's very
cool and you know what I'll I'll brag on
Rick our guy here because I know he's
talking about over in our uh Ramsay
concierge team and um uh all of you
folks out there that own and run
businesses uh that's a leadership lesson
right there uh you know the way our team
is Led they are one of the uh you know
we teach them to have a self-employed
mentality treat this place like they own
it treat the books that you sell like
you own them treat the uh you know the
stuff around here like you know that
like you own it and Rick treated that
like he owned it he said that's somebody
that this is something that if I own
this company I would give that and so he
gave that and oh by the way if you're
running the company your leadership
style needs to equip and Empower your
people to do that to be generous to be
generous without asking they don't need
to check in just do the right thing
and you know he didn't give away ten
thousand dollars he gave away one
one-year membership to financial base
University we'll be okay you know it's
okay and so it's he's equipped he's
empowered to do that all through people
all through this place here and matter
of fact they're more than that it's like
we demand that they do it it's part of
their job to be generous and to take
care of people as one-offs now if you
call in and just you know and if you
call in and make up a lie and try to
mess with us we'll charge a double Okay
so
so we do we do that too because we treat
it like we own it we don't be conned but
we do want to be generous there's a
difference right I mean totally totally
absolutely way to go Rick that's very
very cool stuff that's how it's supposed
to be done so you can uh my my point of
that is is if those of you that run
small businesses out there and lots of
you do your entree leaders entree
leaders meaning you entrepreneurs and
leaders
you can magnify your generosity just by
empowering your team to do it and uh
because they have more touch points
sometimes than you do so it gives you a
lot of ways to do it this is an annual
giving show here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the Ramsey Show Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we do our annual giving show we are
taking calls from those of you telling
your giving stories we're less than two
weeks away from Christmas the Ramsey
Christmas Cash giveaway ends tonight at
midnight and by the time we're done we
will have given away thousands of
dollars why do we do that here at Ramsey
because of one of the things I've
learned is that outrageous generosity
changes me
logically you'd think that being
unselfish makes you a generous person
but the opposite is true being a
generous person changes your heart and
then you become less selfish
and that affects every area of your life
unselfish people are better husbands
better wives better friends better
parents better employers better
employees people just want to be around
you more so when you're fired up because
you're working the baby steps it's
changing your life it is time to start
giving start developing that habit and
while you're over there signing up for
the free money get the ten dollar sale
on The Total Money Makeover books the
baby steps millionaire books all of
Rachel's books you've got hope don't
keep it to yourself spread it around go
to ramseysolutions.com we got the best
deals running right now so it's easy for
you to find outrageously generous gifts
for the season check them out
ramsesolutions.com open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
harmony is in Santa Fe New Mexico Merry
Christmas Harmony
Merry Christmas I am thrilled to talk to
you it is such an honor to participate
in the giving show well thank you tell
us your story
okay so my giving story started a few
years back I got a really nice bonus at
work and I I love my job and I know I'm
good at it but I also know I am nothing
without my team so I wanted to share
and it was kind of a little conundrum
because I wasn't really supposed to
advertise that I'd gotten a bonus I
don't think there were a whole lot of
them giving out that year and I couldn't
just give them money because I don't
think that would have been appropriate
so I did my secret Santa idea I just
made up some envelopes with cash in them
and the person's name and that said from
Secret Santa thank you for all you do
and I snuck around and I flipped them
under the office doors and it was just
so much fun that I decided right then
and there that I would just go ahead and
add a line item to my budget so I could
have a secret santa fun and do it again
so I did it again next year and then I
also noticed how great our janitors are
where I work and of course everything we
do would come to a screeching halt if
they didn't do their jobs amen they're
just always so friendly and cheerful and
they say hi to everybody and they knock
on every door of every office every day
and empty the trash and all the other
things that janitors do so I decided
they would be a part of it too and then
the most amazing thing that happened was
that it went viral one of the janitors
sent an email to the all employees
distribution list that said Thank You
secret santa whoever you are and people
started asking her what was she talking
about no she took a picture of the
envelope and sent that out and then yeah
so this is like
um the entire staff gets these emails
and how many is that Harmony how many
how many people are getting this about
about 500 okay okay that's amazing yeah
so after about a day or so someone
replied to the email chain saying I got
one of those too and then another one me
too and these weren't the ones that I
had given uh
and secret santa stuff started magically
appearing all over the facility oh my
gosh Harmony sounds like Santa got in on
it
I can't believe it it was so fun and I
can't wait to see what happens this year
um because it's we're not quite we work
right up until the day before
um Christmas Eve so it's going to
probably be next week when when things
really I I'm expecting to see it again
this year so and you know it's right
what you said it this is like like
therapy for me there's I get so much
more out of this than I would from any
stuff or even any experiences that I
could buy with the same money well the
fabulous thing is is you inspired
somebody else to start doing it too and
didn't even know it
I think it was it was her email that you
know really got the word out I wasn't I
was tight-lipped I know no one knew
um unless some of the recipients that I
gave
um had said something to somebody else
but um then you know when his email went
out that was really
um what got it going I think that's so
perfect that's awesome well done well
done great story so the original uh
secret santa if there is one is a guy
named Larry Stewart from Kansas City
and um we ended up connecting with him
having him on the show several times
developed a friendship with him he's
passed away a cancer since but Larry was
quite an interesting bird he um was down
on his luck decades ago uh didn't have
any money
was hungry
pulled his pickup into a diner in
Mississippi a little meet and three
Diner went in went up to the counter and
sat down and ate
and uh with the idea that when he
finished he was just going to act like
he forgot his wallet and just try to
talk his because he had to have food he
was hungry
and uh you start talking to the the cook
behind the counter who turned out to be
the owner of the diner we found out
later in the story
um and the guy realized that he was
broke and kind of was running a scam and
uh he walked around behind him and
reached down on the floor and said uh
hey I think you dropped this and handed
him a 20 bill
so he was able to pay for he gave him
the money in other words he was able to
pay for his dinner Larry never forgot
that he later goes on to be he got in
the cable TV business and goes on to
become a multi-millionaire
and um started a tradition of secret
Santa and nobody knew who he was and he
would go to areas of the country where
something had happened he was in New
Orleans after Katrina he was in uh after
a shooting in around Columbine he was
there after that he was in New York City
after 9-1-1 and he would walk around in
a Santa Claus suit with his friends who
were policemen would go with him and he
would give away tens of thousands of
dollars
he'd walk up just hand people hundred
dollar bills 200 bills 300 bills for one
and he would walk around all day long
just on the street and just randomly
coming up to people and just going ho ho
ho and who are you and Jesus Loves You
Jesus loves you and he had and he handed
out over his life he ended up millions
of dollars wow a secret Santa and so
when he got sick
he created the secret santa kit to
franchise it so that other people could
do it and you could go to his I don't
even know if the website's still up he
died several years ago but the website
was like secret santa.com or something
and you could go there and get you know
learn how to be him because finally the
no one knew who it was it was a big
mystery all the media was trying to
track him down trying to figure out what
it was and he kept it a secret for many
years Kansas City Star finally in his
own Hometown tracked him down figured
out who it was and so he came out when
he got sick he came out and told
everybody who he was and started telling
his whole story and we had him on the
air and uh he was just a piece of work
he was a lot of fun but he would dress
up as Santa Claus and go into the areas
of town where people were struggling uh
or go to towns where something had
happened and they just needed
encouragement and it wasn't like five
dollars I mean he's giving away hundreds
hundreds of dollars and hundred dollar
bills and tens of thousands of dollars
on a given trip in a given day
it was very cool he was a great secret
Santa like Harmony Harmony is a great
secret Santa I know well done Harmony
and you know the weird thing is is that
just like uh Larry Stewart's Legacy
lives on and people are now doing Secret
Santas all over in his memory and the
harmony wasn't tracking on him I'm sure
she just had her own idea there but but
if you're tracking that whole idea they
don't know who he is you never know what
you inspire how many of those uh Gen 2
gen 3 generation three secret Santas are
popping up all over uh inspired by you
and what you and I would say I have
enough hope
and Humanity that you know if someone
has given a gift like that that
somewhere in their life they will give
as well right like it's like when you
are given to
you can't help but then to pass that on
right it may look different than the
original gift given to you but that's
where the generosity kind of butter
reflect Butterfly Effect can happen and
it may not happen every single time but
I I have enough faith in humanity that
I'm like I think it does like when
something is given to you
in a Act of generosity your life is
shifted and it changes and then you in
turn want to be able to give to so I
love the the passing on it's inspiring
this thing called generosity this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
this is our annual giving show here on
the Ramsey show we like to inspire
generosity and particularly here at
Christmas time Merry Christmas to you
America we want you to be givers we want
you to enjoy money and the greatest joy
you'll ever get with it is the joy of
generosity one of the ways we also
celebrate this uh day of giving on the
show is we get some of the folks that
work at Ramsey one of the 1100 team
members to come in and tell their giving
or receiving story and uh Sarah is with
us on the debt free stage to tell her
story hey Sarah tell us your giving
story all right so about a year ago and
just in the past few years my
grandmother has been such an incredible
blessing to my family and myself towards
the end of last year in August my
grandfather unfortunately passed away
due to covid but around the same time my
grandmother had made the decision to
sell her her home and move in with my
parents so while this while this was all
happening I was still living at home and
as a family we were like you know what
we're going to go through FPU so we did
and every single video that we watched
because it was a remote class my
grandmother was just sitting on the
couch quietly just listening and
absorbing all the information and I
really believe that something just
changed in her heart that kind of 10xed
her generosity and she was already an
incredibly generous person I mean she'd
be the first one to pay for your food
every time I went out she'd be like oh
and can I slip a few dollars your way
for coffee just the sweetest little
person a you know religious giver and
she also didn't just give her time but
she or give her money but she also gave
her time and part of the ways that she
did that was every single week for as
long as I can remember she would spend a
ton of time making just a ton of food
for her local church youth group and
every single year she also hosts our
Thanksgiving fam family so our
Thanksgiving piece so she would spend
days on end cooking she would invite her
family and not just her family but the
entire church congregation oh my God so
it was a whole feast and she'd spent
days preparing this and she was older in
age so she had a weaker heart and she
couldn't even like just cook it all at
once she literally had to break it apart
that far just to do this wow so it was
just an incredible just inspiring woman
that she did all of this and through
this time uh towards the beginning of
this year unfortunately her health did
start declining but she wanted to make
sure that her daughter's family my mom
was well taken care of so as she was
learning all these principles near
teaching she had made the decision to
pay off her vehicle and a few days later
she told my mom you know what I want you
to put this in your name because she
knew that it would be her vehicle when
she passed and she didn't want my mom to
have that burden of a car payment and
that just helped so much and on top of
that my grandmother was my biggest
cheerleader in my biggest prayer Warrior
as I had made the decision to move from
South Florida to Tennessee to pursue my
dream job here at Ramsey's Solutions oh
fun yeah we she would pray with me
before and after every single interview
on top of that she also helped fund one
of my grad school tuition semesters and
that just helped incredibly as someone
who was on baby step three
and a few months after that she actually
gave me five thousand dollars towards
purchasing my first car wow as I moved
up here uh I needed a reliable vehicle
to get around and I actually moved up
here without the job using the proximity
principle to get the job
and I couldn't have done this like on my
own but with her support I was able to
get my Dave Carr I got my dream job here
and just last weekend I walked for my
graduation for my Master's Degree all
debt free at 21. oh my gosh so I'm super
grateful for the impact that she's had
me on that way in that way but it gets
even better than that and as she was
continuing through financial peace
towards the end you know we have that
generosity video and she actually asked
my mom one day if she would drive her to
the bank now my mom had no idea what
this like why she wanted to go go to the
bank she thought oh maybe she wants to
open an account an account but on the
drive over she actually revealed that
she wanted to pay off my parents house
whoa
completely like two hundred thousand
dollars it was insane and there was
nothing stopping her from doing this wow
so she went ahead and she paid off my
parents house and without that mortgage
payment such a huge weight was just
lifted off my parents shoulders and my
family and I are just so incredibly
grateful for the blessing of that from
her and just her lasting Legacy of
generosity
and as I've moved up here now uh there's
a weekend since I knew that her health
was kind of declining that I had decided
to go back and visit her in South
Florida and I flew in really early I
think like 6 a.m that day and I got to
the home and I was sitting at our
bedside holding her hand my mother was
on the other side also holding her hand
and I got the privilege to spend the
last 20 minutes of her life by her side
and just the lasting impact of
generosity I hope that I can carry that
on Wow and this place helps me do
exactly that so I really am so grateful
to be a part of this Crusade wow you're
incredible what a great story oh I love
your granny she's awesome yes how old
was she when she passed she was 76. 76
okay
yeah how incredible how many how many
grandkids does she have is it you and
it's actually just three three okay okay
yep but I was thinking like that's what
I love about within a family unit right
how it that that trickle effect is so
real and as you're standing here you're
like oh yeah your your life is
completely different uh not just from
the monetary gifts that she's given you
but it's the spirit right that
generosity yeah who she is absolutely
beautiful my mom was like I hope that I
can do that for you guys one day too and
I'm just like as much as we can do we're
trying to be generous and like not just
the big ways but the small ways as well
that's right that's pretty cool very
cool very very well done good stuff good
stuff all right Sarah tell everybody
what you do here and how long you've
been on the team I am an email marketer
with every dollar and I've been here
about eight months and you said you're
21. yes and you just got your Masters
and what in strategic Communications and
Leadership wow very cool well you're a
great team member and that was a
wonderful generosity story very very
well grandmother I love it thanks for
sharing it Sarah thank you for having me
good stuff
generous people make us smile
generous people make our eyes leak I was
crying on that one that one got me that
was good right there powerful yeah yeah
pop a day wiping wiping my tears away
yeah that was good so good stuff ugh
well the granny kicking the grandmother
kicking in and just going boom I'm gonna
do this and boom I'm gonna do that yeah
boom I'm gonna do that and the other
thing that just occurs you know as I'm
sitting there we've got so many
Millennials and gen xers on this team
and they get such a bad rap of as uh
not having hustle not having grind not
having that and uh like so many
stereotypes they're just inaccurate um
there's certainly
a segment of gen Z and certainly a
segment of millennial that's awful and a
segment of the Boomers and a segment
exactly there's no question and but I
got to tell you we work up close and
personal with a bunch of gen Z's that
are like her that that lady right there
is brilliant beautiful 21. great she's
got her you know she's articulate uh
just finishes her master's degree I mean
uh and and is a you know proud member of
this Crusade and so on so you know
they're out there they're out there and
uh that you know when you get to meet
people like Sarah uh you know that we're
gonna be okay the Gen Z is you know
there's enough of her enough those like
her engines that's right yeah good stuff
hey this is our giving theme hour thank
you for our theme show today thank you
for being with us on this it's
absolutely incredible to share these
stories if you've got a great giving
story jump in and we'll uh try to get
you on the phone numbers triple eight
eight two five five two two five live
how our lives have changed Trudy as in
the baby steps Community Facebook group
how our lives have changed since uh
finding the Ramsey Financial Peace
University at our church six years ago
before FPU it would be weeks before
Christmas we'd be scrambling to find
money to pay for gifts make payments on
credit cards today my husband called to
tell me it's giving Tuesday and we still
have a sizable amount of money in our
charity account I stopped decorating the
house and started a poll in our town for
people's favorite Charities this is the
most fun you can have with money before
dinner tonight we are delivering checks
oh there we go all right good stuff
that's the way it's done intentional
giving intentional generosity this is
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
Corinthians 9 6-7 the point is this
whoever sows sparingly
will also reap sparingly and whoever
sows bountifully will also reap
bountifully
each one must give as he has decided in
his heart not reluctantly or under
compulsion for God loves a cheerful
Giver
Ralph Waldo Emerson said you cannot do a
kindness too soon because you never know
how soon it will be too late oh that's a
good one yeah you know he he might have
a future in that writing stuff called
Emerson guy you never know
this is a giving show for the Ramsay
show we do it once a year we should do
it more but we're here celebrating the
power of generosity Grace is in Tyler
Texas Merry Christmas Grace tell us your
giving story Merry Christmas you guys
it's an honor to come on air today to
share my story well my story
um was back in 2020 during the height of
all of the covet shutdowns in the world
spinning it felt like my husband and I
were both fortunate enough to keep
working and keep our jobs and actually
have overtime opportunity as well as we
were doing really good financially
during that time when we know a lot of
people weren't so when those rounds of
stimulus checks started coming in from
the government my husband and I both
agreed that we wanted to use those
checks to bless somebody who was who was
struggling during that time you know we
were praying about it like Lord lead us
to how you would have us use this money
and since there was so many any needs we
didn't know you know which need to meet
there were so many and the Lord put on
my heart to just reach out to a friend
of mine who the year prior had moved to
Uganda with her family to oversee and
operate a a children's home there it's
basically like a foster home for babies
newborn through age five who either
don't have a family or for one reason or
another aren't able to be cared for by
their families and they take care of
these babies and love on them and
provide for them and care for them until
they're either reunited with their
family or are placed with some kind of
permanent you know placement or in some
cases domestic adoption and when I
reached out to my friend I found out
that they had been really hurting
because of all of the lockdowns there in
Uganda the lockdowns were extremely
strict they it was really difficult for
them to be able to leave their facility
they had strong regular relations on
we're regarding that and even when they
were able to leave it's not like all of
the markets were open and bustling and
so they were running quickly out of
supplies for their Clinic medications
equipment as well as clothes for those
grooming babies since babies grow like
weeds and they needed to close in the
next sizes up and were not able to get
them so I asked my friends for a list of
everything they needed for their clinic
in terms of clothes for the office
everything and she sent that over to me
and my husband and I went to Walmart and
completely cleared the list and packed
up five very large boxes and expressed
shipped them internationally to Uganda
for them wow that's fun Grace that's
amazing that is great when they got
those boxes they must have thought Santa
had shown up for sure
yes it was so sweet my friend when the
first boxes started to arrive she opened
it and with some of the older babies you
know the toddler age
um sent me a picture with some of those
babies holding some of the the new
clothes and items from the boxes and
that just it made me cry just from the
joy that I was feeling that I got to be
that we got to be a blessing for them
you know because we you know we were
doing fine financially we didn't need
that money and to be able to bless them
in that way was just so incredible fun
I've had shopping ever
amen that is the most fun ever oh Grace
that's amazing well done Grace very well
done well played I like it Ian is with
us in Milwaukee Merry Christmas Ian
Merry Christmas guys I haven't slept
because I've been so excited to be on
this show
wow I'm sorry we didn't mean to have
that effect how can we help tell us
about it tell us your giving story
um so I am I'm currently 37 uh when I
was 35 I had been a police officer uh
for 13 years and
um I just recently been promoted to
Sergeant
and up until that time I had never had
any inkling of heavy mental health
issues I extremely healthy I've done
everything I ever wanted to do at the
department
and all of a sudden something just
clicked and I was completely debilitated
by a form of OCD where you think you're
going to or you think you did
um harm your kids
and my little girls
um were two and five at the time and I
love being a girl dad
um and I was at work and I'm constantly
around all these bad people and I'm like
oh my gosh that's me I did something I
heard that when I was changing their
diapers and my doctor's like no Ian you
have OCD and you have it so bad you need
to contact Rogers behavioral health
because they're I mean the best in the
business so I I call them and they're
like we need to get you in our
residential program now you are you know
you are one of the most severe cases
we've seen and so I'm like all right
let's do what I called my insurance and
they said no we're we're not covering it
because it's not worded and patient even
though that's what it was
and so I'm thinking my gosh we have we
were in baby steps we still are four
five and six and I said we can cover
this but what happens if my treatment
runs past 12 16 weeks and the department
says you're not fit for Duty we're gonna
leave I mean I was just so scared
because that had been my life and their
Foundation says look we will cover 100
your stay and impatient wow and we will
make sure you you get treated
and the the mental health organizations
Foundation or the Departments Foundation
no the Mental Health Organization oh wow
100 wow
and when when I came out and did like
their their Partial Program and like
daily therapy
um we cash flowed that without touching
our emergency fund wow um and I did the
disability process for retirement all by
myself
um and I was able to retire full pension
um and
I I could not thank them enough because
they they really did save my life 100 in
my family's life and
um you know now I get to be a girl dad I
get to to talk about this I actually
just wrote an article I talked about
this at churches and um leadership
conferences and schools and
um you know you guys are my inspiration
to do that and that's what I get to do
now so
well very well done sounds like you're
doing good are you
I'm doing good
um and you know actually I there's a
couple of people at your organization
Tristan Dawn and Aisha they're listening
today and actually just filled out an
application for one of the positions
with you guys to to give it a shot and
maybe share my talents with you guys wow
very cool Ian very cool that's a
powerful story though and yeah the
generosity that piece is what a burden
that's lifted off you know when you
don't have to to pay for something like
that I mean that's that's absolutely
incredible and you know there's there's
things that are definable and you can
put your finger on mental health things
often aren't as easy to Define I mean if
you need uh heart surgery that's a very
definable objective thing if you've got
uh that form in his case a form of OCD
that's a little tougher to uh diagnose
and to Define that goes oh there's an
end to this treatment yeah you know and
those people stepped up and as he said
literally saved his life that's pretty
incredible very cool and that's the
beauty of having around Health Care
Mental Health or a physical care either
one having foundations and things that
support and move that it's absolutely
vital well guys that's a great giving
show you folks out there did it again
you inspired each other you inspired
America by calling in and giving your
great stories Rachel this whole
generosity thing is a big deal
well it is and it's a huge piece of of
why we do what we do here every day
getting people in a place where they can
be freed up where their money doesn't
control them so that they can truly live
and give like no one else and this is
that peace that we get to celebrate
today so thank you guys so much for
calling in great job Austin Zach Ben
James Andrew in the booth the booth
dudes they make the show happen that
puts this hour in the boot in the shin
oh whatever we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
foreign
co-host on the Ramsay show if you want
to do your debt free stream live on the
show visit ramseysolutions.com set free
screen we'd love for you to come to
Nashville and tell Dave your story
that's ramsesolutions.com debt free
screen
[Music]